[Música]
pese varias semanas de acercamientos y
discusiones entre occidente y rusia
sigue la escalada de tensión que apunta
a una invasión a ucrania que vladimir
putin niega pero al tiempo que justifica
la presencia de tropas y armamento en la
frontera por las expansiones de la otan
a de cerca de sus zonas de influencia el
presidente de eeuu o yubá irene dijo la
semana pasada a su homólogo ucraniano
volodymyr selenski que cree que un
ataque podría ocurrir en febrero cuando
el terreno está congelado y no es clara
la respuesta occidental si éste se
concreta pese a las advertencias desde
washington la otan por ejemplo dice que
no enviaría tropas a dado que ucrania no
hace parte de la alianza por el momento
es posible de prever las tácticas
militares de rusia frente a ucrania por
dónde invadiría a vladimir putin para el
análisis está en directo américa
guillermo pulido analista en el revista
de ejercicios y política leer room y
doctorando en estudios estratégicos de
autor del libro guerra multidominio y
mosaico el nuevo pensamiento militar
estadounidense guillermo gracias a usted
y por donde entraría rusia porque en
febrero
probablemente rusia de decir tienes
varias opciones por las cuales según el
tipo de invasión tendría diferentes
avenidas de aproximación en uno u otro
lugar una opción es entrar a través de
la ciudad de arcos donde ha concentrado
una gran masa de maniobra entre la
vecina ciudad dejar coche en rusia es
velcro y ahí se tienen con centros ya
tiene concentrado por lo menos unos 13
agrupaciones tácticas o batallones
reforzados por los cuales podría entrar
entraría alrededor de la ciudad cerca de
la ciudad de hardcore eso no significa
que entraría dentro de la ciudad pero
sería esa esa ruta de aproximación entre
ver coros y hard post para poder cercar
todo lo que pone silbando y cortar las
líneas de comunicaciones del ejército
del ejército ucraniano que van desde el
norte y el oeste ucraniano pasando
pulsando el dniéper y llegando hasta
atom ese lugar y cruzando a través de
harkov pues cortaría por la mitad hacia
esa ruta de comunicaciones y podría
causar un gran daño al ejército
ucraniano
combatiendo entonces y logramos
además del estupendo que está desplegado
el mariupol y en el mar de azov no por
tanto poder embolsará una gran cantidad
de fuerza sobran ya nos entrando a
través de harkov en caso de guerra sería
una opción bastante
es decir beneficiosa para la reducida
para hacer asestar un golpe muy fuerte
al ejército a las fuerzas armadas
ucranianas con las cuales podrás
negociar e imponer un gran coste al
gobierno de aquí es otra otra otra línea
si si guillermo disculpe es que quisiera
hacerle más preguntas y no tenemos mucho
tiempo malo le preguntaba también el
sobre por qué sería conveniente hacerlo
en febrero en el pasado ya rusia ha
tenido éxito por poner este clima
invernal a su favor podría hacerlo
nuevamente
que febrero como como usted bien dice el
el suele ser los meses más duros del
invierno en rusia y en ucrania y por
tanto sería climatológicamente hablando
sería un momento adecuado para hacer una
ofensiva de dos maneras el aspecto
climático no es determinante lo más
importante son los aspectos políticos si
el aspecto político pues aconseja
retrasar la ofensiva de febrero a marzo
pues sin ninguna duda sería pero desde
luego febrero es un gran momento para
para hacer este tipo de operaciones
militares y de hecho toda la
concentración militar que se ha hecho
durante los últimos meses alrededor de
ucrania cayó alrededor de ucrania y
desde hace una semana y pico también en
bielorrusia todo indica que a mediados
de febrero que alcanzará su punto
culminante porque ha estado durante
varios meses concentrando varios
ejércitos en el en el este del oriente
ucraniano y el 10 de febrero
culminará la concentración en
bielorrusia por tanto a mediados de
febrero
si hay que atacar sería el momento ideal
militar y clamato climatológicamente
prácticamente las cosas podrían
retrasarse bueno y hablando de cómo
están armados los lados en este
conflicto cuál es el poder militar que
tiene cada parte
pues aunque rusia tiene una cantidad es
decir en ucrania tiene cierta su perdida
numérica porque tiene hasta 200 800 mil
soldados aproximadamente y rusia- pues
cuando culmine su concentración tendrá
unos 105.000 el poder militar es muy
superior al de rusia básicamente por la
artillería y la capacidad operativa de
sus carros de combates y de las fuerzas
aéreas
y las brigadas ucranianas tienen poca
capacidad de maniobra tienen también muy
poca artillería y la mayoría remolcada
sin embargo la artillería rusa pues en
cada en cada brigada tienen su propia
lanza 4 artillería con un gran alcance
superior al ucraniano y además tienen
varios batallones de brigadas de
artillería de brigadas reactivas que
podrían destruir la artillería ucraniana
y los batallones de infantería ucraniano
a 100 o 120 kilómetros de distancia sin
que los bucaneros pudiesen devolver el
fuego además rusia tiene superior una
superioridad aérea indiscutible y muchos
misiles de largo alcance de precisión
con los cuales destruir objetivos
estratégicos de la infraestructura civil
y militar ucraniana
eso es el lado ucraniano guillermo pero
claro lo que muchos nos preguntamos es
si hubiese una invasión a ucrania
entrarían otros actores bélicos a ser
parte de este conflicto y hablemos de la
otan y de eeuu por supuesto
y dice que no es la otan y eeuu no
entraría en una guerra en ucrania para
defenderse para defender a ucrania de
rusia eso está descartado la
concentración que está haciendo la otan
y la pequeña concentración de fuerza
militar que está haciendo la otan cerca
de ucrania es para defender a la otan de
algún tipo de aventurismos militar el
ruso o bielorruso en las fronteras de
los países limítrofes de la otan con
rusia y bielorrusia y ucrania no es que
vayan a entrar a defender a ucrania
y estando en la época de la guerra
híbrida y de la guerra proxy porque a
pesar de eso no es descabellado hoy en
2022 pensar en una invasión militar
porque las opciones las llamadas
opciones híbridas y de la guerra proxy
en verdad no no han conseguido los
objetivos que es decir el objetivo de
putin es torcer la voluntad del gobierno
ucraniano para que se imponga que se
impongan los acuerdos demmings y
ucranianos sigue acercándose a los
países occidentales y esto es lo lleva
haciendo rusia del 2014 y no ha tenido
resultados que no ha forzado de acuerdo
a la implica la implementación de los
acuerdos de links y ucrania se ha ido
acercando progresivamente a los pasos de
occidente por tanto si quien si rusia
quiere imponer su voluntad al gobierno
ucraniano dado que las opciones
civilidad las más llamada opciones
híbridas no han tenido han dado
resultado pues no le queda más remedio
que escalar eso lo que explica la
concentración militar de poder militar
convencional en la frontera ucraniana